there's no time o clock Bongiorno
ladies and gentlemen Italian serial
killers yeah getting back to the true
crime on this one cuz I feel like well
we did West Memphis Three that still
counts as true crime but we had been
doing like other stuff like Illuminati
and other kind of paranormal things so I
did have a couple requests to go back to
doing some true crime which of course is
my favorite thing to do and I had been
wanting to do this one for a while I've
gotten so many requests for various
serial killers in various weird murder
cases that what I started doing was that
I started like grouping them like by
what country they you know happened in
or if there was like some particularly
if there was cannibalism or there were
some cuz I'm trying to like you know
work through a lot of them and so I'm
trying to like put ones together that
we're kind of like you're related so
these two were the two that came up in
my Italian serial killer Bank and I
thought that we would do these ones
because these were ones that the second
one is kind of like a little bit better
now and I thought I think cuz I did find
like some more things about her like
particularly she's a female serial
killer which there's not a lot of those
but the first person whom I'm assuming
is a guy but they don't know because
they haven't caught him there is very
very little on this first serial killer
in English and even in Italian I only
found like two or three pages that I had
to translate there's an english-language
Wikipedia page but it's very very sparse
so I basically like went through and
found like a couple of articles in
Italian and then like translated them
into English and then tried to kind of
piece it together from there so
hopefully it's like fairly accurate but
if anybody could speak Italian and like
can like read some of the pages and tell
me if I [ __ ] anything up then I
appreciate being corrected on any of
that because like I said there's not a
lot of english-language material on the
first guy but I actually I think I heard
of him first when I was when I was
reading about the monster of Florence
because remember we did that show was
probably it was months and months ago we
did the monster of Florence and the
vampire pan over like you know European
serial killer yeah so while I was
researching that I think I ran into this
guy who never got caught so I wanted to
do him as well and like I said we need
to do more female serial killers so I
also wanted to do the second woman who's
the soap maker of courage you know yeah
you guys you guys request this she had a
lot to me this stuff's usually
depressing but we'll see everything is
depressing
he's kind of president okay we'll do it
I mean it well and I might have you know
kind of talked about this a little bit
before but it's like true crime stuff
you know I write about it all the time I
read about it all the time it's
depressing but it's also really
interesting I guess because it's a
mystery and I like mysteries
particularly ones that haven't been
solved because I like to try and like
bigger amount okay you know what I mean
um even though it's horrible and like
people died and things like that but if
you know other people have the same
thing it's not like I'm weird or
anything like people love this [ __ ] I
thought we maybe we should have live
stranger this yet well no because I
don't want to get into well I don't want
to get into habit of like live-streaming
every single major episode where am i
well one I don't want to wear them out
and two it's like you know they've
gotten so used to the show's going up on
Tuesday and that it's like we usually
record them like a you know font Friday
or Saturday yeah and I don't want to
like mess up a you know the schedule
where like everyone's expecting you to
go but I do want a still live stream at
least one Episode a month though maybe
two and we still like are doing we're
live streaming matinee shows we're live
streaming sidetrack shows yeah and I
still want to keep doing that so but I
do think that you know we'll do at least
one or two live streams of the main
episodes a month but I'll always
announce whatever day we're gonna do it
it'll probably be a Friday or Saturday
night just like last time because I feel
like we got a lot of people who did it
Saturday night last time right yeah yeah
and we got a lot of people come to that
so that was like pretty cool so that
seemed like the best thing so we'll
probably be like a Saturday but this one
we're gonna record and I'm just gonna
put it up like a radio show
it's like Friday like 6 o'clock in the
afternoon right now we're 6 like 6
o'clock in the evening I was sleeping
make a drink
yeah such a rough life got a he's like
the kitty
yeah it's summertime starting yes she is
also sleeping starting starting to get
hot so I try to just like hide like a
cat I tell you what as long as the a/c
is gone I'm [ __ ] happy it's like Lord
well because I still have to go out and
you know and you know do my power walks
and do my exercise and stuff like that
because I don't really have room to put
a [ __ ] exercise bike or uh yeah
they're doing thing I was shopping today
I bought [ __ ] oh [ __ ] ton of supplies
you did [ __ ] he made a big huge Santa
it's like it was like it was like going
to [ __ ] I felt like Neville devil
going out there dealing with the damn
family the Omega Man the last man on
earth
yeah during a pandemic yeah it was
probably crowded there right now wasn't
that bad it wasn't that crowded no it
saturday is this one it doesn't like
really crowded shopping with an old
Jamaican lady where she's there girl
what kind of bread is this did she think
you worked there oh [ __ ] dope it's
bad
well I was walking by you know she's in
the in the bakery section of the Sam's
and she goes which one of these French
bread today yeah and I said said that
one right there and she was the fresh
breath round and I said not the United
States yeah like a baguette thank you
yeah and she's gonna say this is French
bread I can't do it Jamaican accent I'm
not eating yeah and she's like my son
loves this she's older lady you guys my
son loves this but it's usually round I
said no not not in the United States
yeah yeah bread it's always blog like
the backlog and baguette baguette what
do they call that what do they call the
round blue if I don't even know what the
flower knows she's either from Jamaica
Haiti you know I didn't ask her it was
like a hit
can't tell there's two yeah Haitian
accent in Jamaica Texas I think they're
slightly thinner they're similar I think
she might have been
it's my termination actually yeah my
termination hard to tell she was like no
that's a braid looks like she's like I
supposed to round my son likes roundness
is not in this country but she she just
come from Canada okay I guess cuz she
said in Canada
she had a French accent maybe she was
Canadian yeah it was right she's kind of
a French shouting from Quebec or
something like that yeah not smelling
like that there's a strong accent you
did yeah we bought like a whole bunch of
stuff yeah whole bunch of stuff yeah I
got [ __ ] [ __ ] ton of [ __ ] ton of [ __ ]
is too two months worth of food yeah not
the way we eat two weeks from now
it's all gonna go well cuz it's there
we're gonna eat it you know to have the
good plumber
oh yeah Audrina [ __ ] I you know what
it's like as as fairly well this house
isn't new new but it's like 10 or 11
years old and it's kind of like
expensive like as the neighborhood and
[ __ ] like that the plumbing is not yeah
happy shower always plugs up shower
drink like every week or something like
yeah it's like it'll work for a little
while on sudden no a lot of and it's not
just my hair I know my hair falls out
yeah I do [ __ ] I shed more than the
kitty does yeah I can't help it man it's
like I don't like it any more than you
do I have like this huge like super long
like thick hair every time I brush it
like a whole [ __ ] ton comes out every
time I wash it all [ __ ] ton pulls out
it's like it's terrible I'm surprised
I'm not bald by now we're getting
sidetracked again
what else did okay what kind of what
kind of shoutouts do we have okay so I I
think I've shouted out all of these
people like on the sidetrack show and
everything like that but like I said I
like to do on the main ones cuz I know
everybody doesn't watch the sidetracks
so I want to say a big thank you and
welcome to our three new patrons that we
had this week Thomas Melissa G and
Sidney Shaw so hey thank you she's
getting bigger yeah also we got PayPal
donations from Sophie are okay so I'm
frozen
and also Dan who is also one of our
patrons actually and we I would also
like to give a huge thank you to
everybody that gave donations on our
livestream is great luck because yeah
like even the main and even some of the
smaller live streams we did we had
people give donations on that touka said
it's like super awesome like I said I
don't I never expect it but it's like
it's really really appreciated that you
guys do that
and like I said we're gonna keep this
going as long as we can keep it going
yeah cuz we're having a good time long
does this remaining steady or grow and
we'll continue to do it yeah if it ever
starts falling apart we'll just make a
new channel fire ollie and make a new
channel yeah well I just you know
creativity's like that you know people
garnish didn't if they're not interested
in it anymore we'll just make another
one yeah and do something different
well in some when we had a lot of ideas
some YouTube shows that I like have been
going for a really long time like look
at like [ __ ] I like cinemassacre that
dudes been on for more than 10 years
welcome to the basement and when your
board games yeah they've been going more
than 10 years yeah they've been going
like [ __ ] 11th or something like that
they might doing that [ __ ] so yeah it's
like you know not not out of the
question
all right so let's get to the crime now
the first serial killer that we're gonna
be talking about and like I said this
one is still unidentified now this
individual is thought to be responsible
for at least four but possibly as many
as 16 murders in the city of Buda nay
Italy and hence he is called the monster
of Odin a I am assuming that it's a man
I'm also they're not really sure if this
is one dude or possibly two dudes like
not related because the thing about it
is that almost all the victims not all
of them but most of them were
prostitutes
before that there considering I guess
the canonical
monster of you de neige crimes they had
a very particular calling card left on
the bodies and they were killed in a
particular way they were mostly stabbed
but there were there was a huge spike in
prostitute murders between 1971 and 1989
like prior to 1971 there had only been
like one or something like that and then
there were like between those years
there were like 13 or 14 of them and
then like after 2004 there were none so
there was definitely something going on
in this time period they do think that
like I said the the four that were you
know this one particular that there was
this one particular calling card left at
the scene they know that that was almost
surely that the same dude the other ones
like could be the same dude and it was
just changing it up or could be a
different dude although I don't know if
they think they're working together or
anything like that so let's kind of get
into this now okay so this happened in a
place in Italy called Friuli now like I
said at first because there had been
such a big spike in these prostitute
murders now it should be noted that
there were there are a lot of like
military barracks in this particular
place so it's speculated that some of
the prostitutes that were murdered might
have just been one offs you know so it's
not necessarily like you know a one
serial killer that's responsible for all
of these crimes you know or they could
have been like killed by their pimp or
whatever or something like that but the
fact that there were so many in this
particular span of time and that at
least four of them had this like very
very particular calling card made them
think that there's at least one serial
killer so the four that have been for
sure attributed to the monster of Hugh
de neige the very particular thing that
this serial killer does is that he
generally stabs the women several times
and then at
they're dead he takes a tool which they
believe is a scalpel or something
equivalent and he cuts like this s
shaped like vaguely s-shaped kind of cut
like on their abdomen like all the way
to the top of the pubis region almost
like a cesarean section so they're
speculating much like in the case of
Jack the Ripper that this guy might be
someone with some medical knowledge or
you know obstetrics something of that
nature cut goes through the abdominal
wall or it's just a cut on the skin I'm
not really sure because like I said
there's not a lot of english-language
information about this case and the
translations that I read were pretty
like pretty clear but none of them
really specified whether I mean they did
seem to say that these injuries were
postmortem so this definitely seems like
something that this person is doing like
to leave a mark you know what I mean so
I don't know like how deep the actual
cut is because I don't think from
anything that I read it didn't seem to
it didn't seem to speculate that it that
that was what caused it most like most
of their causes of death were like
stabbing like they were like stabbed in
the throat they were stabbed a bunch of
times they bled to death or something
like that so yeah so as I said now
between the 1950s which I assume was
when they started kind of keeping
records this kind of stuff in between 19
1971 there was only one prostitute
murder in Newton a like I said and then
between 1971 in 1990 there were 13 and
then from oh it's thunder yeah yeah it's
my storm so hopefully the power would go
out and then from 1991 to 2004 there
were three and then after 2004 there
weren't anymore so like I said this was
definitely a spike in definitely an
anomaly so because these four particular
ones had been stabbed and then there
were a bunch of other ones most of whom
had been strangled one of whom was set
on fire
they're speculating that there's at
least two killers so the monster of Odin
a when they talk about that that's
mostly just the stabbing guy they don't
really have a name for the strangler guy
so they're kind of like putting them all
in one pot but at the same time saying
we don't know if that's the same person
because the mo is so different and
because the monster of you de neige also
has a couple of other things that he
does like he always kills women like in
the same months of the year it's always
raining like when he strikes it's always
like the same day of the week [ __ ] like
that like he always has like a kind of
thing that he does so the most recent
thing that happened in this case and
like I said I couldn't find a great deal
about it but in March of last year 2019
I guess the lawyers of a couple of the
victims had like comfort and they're
trying to get like the case reopened
because it seemed like they're they're
not really making a lot of progress on
the case even though they're pretty sure
that this is you know maybe two
different people so here are the victims
some of whom have been attributed to
monster of you today some of them might
be the same guy might be a different guy
so the first woman that's usually put
into the you know roster of victims or
whatever is a woman named Irene valetti
now she was killed on September 21st
1971 and she was stabbed multiple times
that's what killed her
the second one was killed in November
1972 her name was Elsa Maroussi now she
was actually strangled so again we're
not sure if that's the same person it's
just very unusual that all of these
prostitutes are getting killed in the
same time period December 1975 there was
another victim named Eugenia tilling and
she was stabbed in the throat then there
was another stabbing victim in on
September 21st 1976 maria luiza bernardo
again she was also stabbed like all over
the body
Jacqueline Breck blur also stabbed that
was in 1976 now a 19 year old prostitute
named Maria Carla Bologna Bologna she
was killed on February 19th nineteen
80 now this was the first victim to show
that cut that I was talking about the
one that looks like looks like a
cesarean scar although like I said if
you'll notice like several of the
victims prior to that were also stabbed
but did not have that particular marking
so I don't know if this is just because
I think prior to that it was there was
one strangled but all the other ones
were stabbed so I'm kind of thinking
that maybe this might all be this I
don't know if the strangling and the
stabbing of the same person they don't
I mean serial killers don't usually
change up their methods but it's not
impossible you know what I mean now the
next one that happened this one seems so
different that I don't know if this
one's related to the other ones now this
was a girl named William Wilma Ginn now
she was actually found in a landfill in
March of 1980 and she had been burned to
death like she had been it was just
charred her body was just charred
now she was not a prostitute she had
actually been like at a dance hall or a
ballroom or something like that she
disappeared from there she was just like
you know regular girl or and she wasn't
a working girl or anything now a guy who
was arrested and indicted for this
particular crime they don't say his name
but he was from a purely oak or Puglia I
guess is the name of it so in the
southern peninsula peninsular area of
Italy but he got exonerated so I don't
know if he had anything to do with it or
whatever he had actually been he had a
prior arrests for like I guess like
either pimping or you know soliciting
prostitutes like I said there's not a
lot of information about this so from
what I could determine from the
translation they said crimes involving
prostitution so that could mean a lot of
friends job yeah so um but so but the
victim in this case was not a prostitute
she was just like a girl that was at a
club or at a bar or whatever so there
why is this linked in with the other
ones that doesn't sound like it um just
because this was part of a series of
crimes that occurred somewhere where
crimes like this didn't occur and it was
just like a spike and this sounds like
one often this one yeah that one of all
the other one sounds like a one-off all
the other ones were stabbed or strangled
which would suggest to me either the
same person changing up their MO or two
different guys yeah and operating the
other one so you're talking about the
guy isn't real he's not real concerned
with evidence being found he's leaving
city signatures behind letting the body
be found this guy here is trying to hide
evidence that's why he's trying to burn
to burn it yeah and dump return yeah so
it's not the same guy yeah so I
definitely think that that is good like
I said they usually put that in the
series just because she was another
young woman that was killed during the
same time period but it sounds like a
dude that was real paranoid about
getting caught yeah he was trying to
erase any evidence it's not the same guy
yeah and that well yeah that's what I
thought too and like I said whether the
guy that was indicted for it and later
exonerated whether that was the dude
that did it or who knows now then there
was another woman who was 22 he was a
prostitute
her name was Lou Anna jump or cop jump
or karo and she was killed on January
24th 1983 she was also stabbed and she
also had that signature cut that's this
Aryan cut Maria boo kvass
she was killed in May 1984 but strangled
there was another woman named Matilda's
Annette now she was killed in September
of 1984 and a guy was arrested for that
his name was Gian Luigi Jim Gianluigi
Sebastien is I'm sorry I'm like mangling
these names really bad but I don't know
if he was ever convicted all I saw in
the translation was that he was arrested
for it but it didn't say whether he was
convicted or not so I don't know if that
crime is solved but it's usually put in
the same series then there was another
woman named Stowe Janka yuksam ovitch
and she was killed in December 1983 and
she was strangled Aurelia janeshia
whit's she was 42 she was also a
prostitute she was killed on March 3rd
1985 she was the third victim to have
that cut
now the next victim again not a
prostitute
she was actually a primary school
teacher her name was Marina leprae she
was 40 years old she was killed on
February 26th 1989 now what happened in
her particular case at least according
to her daughter who was a little kid at
the time I think she was only nine and I
guess she may be like witnessed it or it
was outside her house or something like
that she said that a guy that her mom
was like walking down the street and a
guy stopped and offered her a ride and
then later took her somewhere and
murdered her now the fact that she was
not a prostitute was kind of a big deal
but I think that like investigators
speculated that because she was like
walking in the street and accepted a
ride from somebody that he may be
perceived that she was a prostitute she
got in the car with him that's from what
I could determine like I said take a lot
of this with a grain of salt because
there's really not like a huge amount of
english-language information about this
case and some of the translation was
good but it was like kind of like well
it was not super clear you know what I'm
saying this is Italy right yeah yeah yes
maybe Italians got into people's cars in
the 80s without thinking much of it I
mean you know they used to hitchhike in
this country until people got wise to
that but yeah I feel like that happened
a lot up until well probably up until
the 80s I think mostly the 60s in the
70s in the US were kind of the heyday of
people doing that yeah because I've
written about a lot of cases where
people hitchhiked and the thing is it's
like hitchhiking was so widespread yes
it's super dangerous and everybody
figured that out but the thing about it
is that every like tons of people
hitchhiked in the 60s and 70s and the
large majority of them did not get
murdered it's like so you only hear
about the ones that did but still I
would not advise it was strange because
cars were cheap at that time yeah I want
people buying their own cars I don't
know yeah weird could be that the kid
was real little when it happened she was
nine I think on from what I could
dessert that's old enough to know
whether or not your mom knows the guy
yeah maybe it was somebody like me or
maybe it was like an acquaintance yeah
the guy lived in the neighborhood yeah
maybe that's what it was maybe she just
and maybe not and think anything up 9
you would think a kid would be old
enough to perceive that is somebody that
the mom knew maybe not I don't know
unless she couldn't cuz I I wasn't real
clear on because I saw a couple of
different sites that had this particular
detail about the girl claiming that her
mom got into a car with this guy but I
didn't get I mean none of them really
went into you if the little girl saw
what the guy looked like or her little
girl get in the car with him that's what
I mean it's like I didn't yeah and I
don't know where the little girl was in
relation to her mom like did she just
see her mom like walking down the street
in front of the house in which case why
did she need a ride somewhere unless she
was going somewhere away from the house
you know maybe she was going out the
door like she was gonna walk down to the
store or something like that and then a
guy pulled up at the curb and said hey
and she kind of knew him or he was an
acquaintance or something hey I'll give
you a ride up to the store and then like
she never saw him yes I heard mom again
so it might have been something like
that that's what I'm thinking like I
said it was just the wit the description
of it is like really really vague okay
you don't I mean and I'm not really sure
those are my gut instinct is they she
knew him yeah or at least knew of him or
had seen him around like enough that
maybe he wasn't threatening perhaps it
makes more sense that she knew him yeah
because most people I feel like even in
the early even in 19 well this was 89
even and I mean in 1989 you don't jump
in a car you don't get in a car with
somebody right I mean I wouldn't well
you know what I mean I wouldn't do that
ever so what that's the thing now a
weird thing about this particular case
was that when her body was found she had
a bunch of keys in her hand and they
weren't her keys so they never did
figure out who those keys belong to so
that's another pin yes that's yeah
that's what they were thinking that's
what they were investigating like that
this must have been his keys and she
snatched him off him or he left him on
ER for some weird reason she also had
the cut so she was the fourth and final
victim to have that particular calling
card
maybe he just had a set of keys on him
and it would throw him off the track
trail it's like like a diversion yeah he
found some old keys somewhere maybe
something like yeah and he thought it
would be like some bizarro the track
yeah could be cuz that's the thing about
and here's the thing like I cuz you know
I love all those um you know all these
kind of like true crime shows and [ __ ]
and sometimes I'll just like while I'm
work and I'll like sit and let him cycle
through like criminal II Listed and a
lot of kind of stuff and he does a lot
of shows about you know unsolved murders
with like weird clues and you always
kind of have to think that maybe
somebody that's like some weird serial
killer type person it's like they're
probably as fascinated as true crime as
everybody else and it's like so if they
kill somebody and leave some bizarre
clue at the scene not only will look is
the crime more likely to get talked
about because everybody loves like
mysterious clues like left at the scene
but also it's very easy to like throw
off an investigation because I mean for
the very best reasons like they do
actually have to investigate every lead
because it might have something to do
with who killed the person so it's
really easy to like kind of throw a
monkey wrench in the whole [ __ ] works
just by leaving some really weird like
esoteric kind of [ __ ] nothing is it
might be part of his signature in terms
of he can remember that crime because
that was the one he put the key but the
keys in her hand the way he can remember
the crime and later on if he's ever
caught if he's questioning about it or
he's questioned about it or he can
contact the police and go yeah I left
keys in her hand it's me that type of
stuff yeah that's another things a way
to differentiate them from the from one
from another that way they don't blend
in because you think that you would
think that this guy if he's a serial
killer of course he's got to kill
multiple victims they might start to
kind of blur together so he might do
certain things to him to kind of make
him different so he could remember him
yeah especially as the series goes on it
just goes on and if this was mostly the
same guy I mean you're talking about
this wasn't like a whole [ __ ] ton of
crimes like in a very brief period of
time there was like
times a year between them sometimes a
couple years between them you know what
I mean
yes so it's not like he was like doing a
mall like in a six week period or a lot
of guys I talked to the cops you know
like the like the Zodiac killer they get
the cops attention and identify
themselves by describing the crime scene
in a way that only the yeah perpetrator
would know because you know the cops get
inundated by a bunch of [ __ ] false
confessions and false [ __ ] so you know I
mean they know that
so he's like hey it's me I'm the one
that killed the girl in what you call
that she had the keys in her hand it was
me we know that yeah it had green keys
and red keys you know that that kind of
[ __ ] yeah well yeah cuz good ol way that
way he can give a message to him his
good old BTK did that [ __ ] deal of his
cereal boxes yeah and all the [ __ ] that
he would write like a very detailed like
where like where all the victims were in
the house and how they were laying and
what they were wearing and all this
stuff because that's the thing about
serial killers is that you know
particularly ones like you know sexual
sadists and stuff like that like BTK
it's like the whole reason they do it is
so they can relive the [ __ ] later on
like for whack off material yeah yeah so
they will remember it cuz honestly and
this is not like said in an admiration
type of way or anything like that but
honestly again many years later when
they finally caught Dennis Rader he had
like an almost like a perfect memory of
every single scene it was like itched
into his mind like every single crime
scene like exactly the way it was
because he wanted to remember it like
that like you know and he had drawn it
he had done like all kinds of cuz that's
how he got off like remembering it means
of course he spent a lot of time at the
scene was standing there watching
looking at it yeah admiring it and [ __ ]
because holy crap it's like I can't even
remember what the [ __ ] I ate for
breakfast is runnin much less right what
happened like [ __ ] 20 years ago
that's all I'm thinking maybe some of
this stuff about you know like putting
keys in the hand that might be a way to
differentiate him in the money it might
be yeah and maybe the keys were even I
mean we were his they were his but they
were something he found right they were
just ones that he found that he just put
there's like a [ __ ]
you're right and he goes well this is
the one has two keys in her hand I'll
remember that that's happened do ya now
there was another woman killed in
September of 1991 and her name is Nicola
Perabo now she was actually strangled
and her body was buried I believe
shallowly now it should be noted that
most of the other bodies at least from
what I could determine some of them they
didn't say like wit like where exactly
they found the bodies like whether they
were buried or whether they're just
laying there or whatever but I know at
least two or three of them were found
like in rivers or on riverbanks they
were just kind of dumped so the fact
that this one Barrett was buried I think
this might be a different dude now adieu
dw-- us arrested for this one his name
was Bruno later but again I don't know
if he was convicted but he was arrested
for that murder so I don't know if that
one is part of the series now there were
also like some other women some of whom
were prostitutes killed later on
from 1996 up to 2010 I believe her 2004
rather some of those are unsolved but
they don't know if they're the same
series or not now there were two women
killed in 2004 I think or maybe it was
2006 and they were both killed by a
crossbow but they actually caught the
guy that did that and he committed
suicide in 2010 now he was he was a
serial killer in terms for sexual motive
I'm imagining I don't know much about
him his name is Ramon Burrell oh so that
guy just a crossbow killer yeah yeah
well that they know of
I didn't look that guy up I should look
that guy up and see if he killed other
people
yeah because wasn't there was a guy in
[ __ ] I guess it was in England I
can't remember his name Stephen
something goddamn it I was just reading
about him the other day and he's called
the crossbow cannibal like that was kind
of his thing there he was like crossbow
women and like eat part of them yeah
didn't know that one yeah I think he's
British please correct me if I'm wrong
anybody that's in the UK but he was I
thought his name was Stephen something
mmm god damn it because I was writing
about him because some of the unsolved
cases that I've been writing about cuz
it's not it's fairly recent it was like
early to late 90s or
mm something like that because some of
the unsolved crimes that I was writing
about they you know speculated that
maybe he had done it or he was one of
the suspects that they were looking at
for that for them you know what I mean
I'm not sure like offhand I don't want
to say because I'll probably get it
wrong but I'm not sure offhand how many
people he killed but he did eventually
get caught so as far as the monster of
Judah nee goes like I said you know at
least those four but some of the other
ones like I said were stabbed and things
like that too so it's possible that the
that he killed as many as it's usually
said between four for sure up to between
13 and 16 because there were a lot of
unsolved murders of prostitutes and
other women that happened around that
time so they did actually drop kind of a
psychological profile of this
[ __ ]
um male obviously medical training
probably of some sort probably had
hatred for women hatred for prostitutes
in particular they think that this was
someone who probably had a normal job
you know worked a 40-hour workweek like
a normal person probably at the start of
the murders which were in the early
1970s was between 30 and 40 years old
someone who was a control freak not
severely mentally ill because some of
the crimes were yet more organized they
didn't seem particularly disorganized
they seemed like kind of planned out but
somebody that you know needed control of
things you know I mean so probably not
anyone with any like really severe
mental illness do you Angelo come to
mind
yeah yes somebody like that that was you
that's who I thought of as well yeah um
and they think that this is probably
someone who has a family probably a wife
and kids um and is probably fairly
successful at whatever his work is like
I said they think it's something in the
medical profession probably just from
the injuries that were on those four
bodies in particular D'Angelo Rader
something like that yeah that's kind of
the vibe I'm getting to this definitely
seems like a sexual sadist type of
murder
none of the none of the sources I read
mentioned anything about the women being
sexually assaulted so I mean I would
imagine that if they had been they would
have more DNA evidence and stuff like
that so maybe not huh he was hunting
women yeah it definitely does seem like
that was kind of his end goal kind of
like the most dangerous game but with a
knife yeah yeah because the thing about
that Jack the Ripper's fan yeah is that
sexual sadism doesn't necessarily always
entail rape I mean it does most of the
time it's a sexual motive but yeah it's
yes those are two different things cuz
Dennis Rader did not rape his victims
usually sometimes he would jerk off on
them after they were dead
yeah or you know do various things
because he just got off on seeing them
tied up and helpless you know what I
mean so he didn't really need to rape
them no the fantasy was enough yeah
because he just like got into bondage
yeah he just got all [ __ ] you know he
didn't need any penetration it was just
damn bondage turned a bomb yeah yeah
this guy is gonna be something like that
this is yellow although D'Angelo the
absolute [ __ ] would go in yeah that
edge right there you know he's a little
dick [ __ ] to begin with but you
know
yeah micro dick yeah so what they said
he said he had [ __ ] issue I'm not
[ __ ] on people with micro dick cuz I
know they can't help it like that's just
but I mean I'm just picking on him for
having a micro dick he was jumpy because
he was a [ __ ] horrible person yeah
does that was part of his problem yeah
he felt like he was inadequate so he was
gonna kill a [ __ ] behind it
which that's not the proper response
well shouldn't need to be said but I get
it that's need to be said
that's not how you compensate yeah let's
just not use I cannot deal with it that
Chang how about that trying to
overcompensate you know but yeah it's
gonna be somebody kind of like D'Angelo
I think more D'Angelo than [ __ ] BTK
yeah somebody in and maybe zodiac not
quite as fantasy prone but somebody who
wants to hunt people hunt hunting women
cuz they're bad that's in his mind yeah
they're bad because that really does Jim
like a common thread or a lot of these
types of serial killers and he can pop
out like he's a real [ __ ] impressive
[ __ ] predator of the of the wicked
type of deal yeah I mean he really
thinks he's a badass but he's doing this
it's uh issues [ __ ] issues but like
you said probably has wife
so something from something from his
earlier earlier childhood feelings of
[ __ ] maybe helplessness around women
something like that trying to take I
feel like a lot of these serial killers
and we've talked about this in a lot of
the different shows and like they
usually hate their mom yeah maybe I'm
thinking with this it might have been
something you know yeah I might have
been something like that with the mom
but it also might have been early
childhood experiences maybe he was me
humiliated by some girls or something
and it stuck with him it's something
weird they'll never catch the guy that
uh he was doing this back in the 70s and
80s he's dead now probably well yeah
I'll get into that a little bit cuz
they're actually they did have like one
vague suspect like I said I got this
from a translated site because
apparently they did kind of a
documentary type of thing a few years
back called monster of Eden a that was
on Italian TV and they had like a little
bit of a transcript or you know kind of
a you know a summary of like what
happened on it and cuz you know what I
couldn't tell exactly what they were
saying but I kind of like got the gist
of what they were saying but I'll get
into that a little bit Oh another thing
that they wanted to say too was that he
was probably one of the ones that aged
out of murdering that once you get to a
particular age he just stopped doing it
but that he that he just kind of blended
back into like normal life again so that
was another thing that was in the
profile now the guy that they
looking at like I said they don't they
didn't name him but this guy was
actually a surgeon which they thought
was interesting now he kind of came on
the police radar because when cops were
investigating the death of Maria leprae
who was killed in 1989 the cops they had
gone they had found her body on this
kind of country road they had found her
like in the morning and they had taken
the body away and done all you know the
the forensic shed and everything and
then they left and then later on that
evening a couple of cops went back to
the site interestingly there was a car
parked at the site where the body had
been dumped now originally when the cops
pulled up to the site they thought it
was other cops because it was dark and
they couldn't really say they just saw a
car sitting there and thought oh it's
you know a couple cops are already here
so they drove up with their headlights
off go and we're gonna scare them haha
you know cuz you know I guess dark humor
you have to have like of their murder
scenes or whatever so then they get up
to the car and it's not cops it's this
old guy in a car by himself and old how
old they didn't say they just said it
was there was one old man it just said
one old man in the car that's what the
translation of what they said on the
documentary so so they said but they
thought it was weird that the car was
parked like right there where the body
had been found I mean it could have just
been some looky-loo that just came I was
like who a body got found here you know
what I mean so some weird I don't know
so they said that they asked him for
something and then they pretended like
they left and then the but then they
stayed and they like watched him like
secretively and then they said that so
while they were watching him they said
he went into this abandoned church and
knelt on the ground and started like if
they said quote murmuring strange
litanies praying like he was like yeah
like that and they were like huh that's
odd well they got weird people he might
need to been praying or pretending to
pray who knows maybe he was into some
occult [ __ ] yeah I don't know what that
was about but yeah they thought that was
a little weird so I guess they got the
dude's name and they looked into his
past and they said he had had like some
psychiatric problems in the past I
assumed that he had been like you know
seeking treatment or he had been in a
mental hospital or something now they
did question him about this particular
case and he said he didn't have anything
to do with it he's like I just drive on
these like remote country roads because
I don't like the traffic on the main
roads that's what he said
yeah so he lived with his brother like
in this old house now when they looked
into his past again they found this
really another really weird thing about
his past
they said somewhere around 1977 or 1978
and remember the murders started in 1971
so this would have been like right peak
in the middle of the series so somewhere
around 1977 1978 he was sitting or
standing on the bed of the Toray River
where the bodies of marina leprae and
Maria Carla Maloney
would later be found and he had all his
surgical instruments and he was
pretending to do an operation on a
patient but there was nobody there
damn that's creepy yeah as the suspect
evidently did have some kind of medical
fast and this guy was a surgeon I don't
know what kind of surgeon but okay was
this out in the [ __ ] zeitgeist
were the Italians printing that it was a
surgical type since I'm not real sure I
could bet you they contaminated the
[ __ ] maybe it could be the breast
because like I said there's not a lot of
information in English about this
because I kind of got interested in it
when I was you know research and monster
foreign societies were not notorious for
shitty police work and shitty
courts I got a feeling that the [ __ ]
the tabloids got a hold of these cases
and gave out all the [ __ ] information
and
well that's a weird thing to do well go
out to like attracted some [ __ ]
weirdo [ __ ] hex surgeon and he's
praying and took Yoda I mean he is
probably the kind of guy to confess to
it even when he didn't do it even if he
didn't do it he's probably one of those
County I don't know somebody did it but
this is the only guys it's not the
proper if there's an old old man yeah
see I'm not sure how it's not typical
that an old man commits T's because well
okay but the thing is the crimes had
started in 1971 when they saw him in the
car where the body was that was 1989 so
and they thought that he'd been between
30 and 40 when he started the crimes so
by 1989 he would have been pretty old
what and like I said 1989 well they
didn't have enough evidence to arrest
all he was doing was sitting there he
wasn't doing anything like suspicious I
think maybe he might have been
reminiscing huh usually it just seemed
very odd that they cuz I mean 1989 that
was pretty much the last one yeah you
know what I mean that was the last one
in the series they stopped after that I
mean there was one in 1991 but they
think that was somebody else so if that
was indeed the guy maybe he was like
that was his like big send-off that was
his finale so he's like I'm just gonna
sit here and like bask in the last
murder that he did I don't know as you
know I'm not I'm not saying that was the
dude I don't know what his name is they
didn't say it wasn't arrested he wasn't
questioned over it he was questioned but
he did say that I mean they looked into
his past I'm like I said that's when
they came up with the weird [ __ ] about
the doing a surgery on somebody that's
not their kind of thing was he
eliminated uh no cuz he died okay
he died in 2007 I believe so
they don't was never suspect he was a
suspect they questioned him but they
never arrested him cuz they didn't have
enough evidence they just thought he was
the only guy that they looked at you
know really seriously just because of
all this weird [ __ ] that I mean he's
been seen he was seen at the scene of
the of the 1989 murders now but were
they commonly known see I don't know I
don't know and when he was doing the
weird like you know surgery on the
invisible person thing
that was on a river where he where the
killer would later dump two bodies
there's not enough known that's what I
need to know that all of this was in the
Italian press where all the bodies were
found and the nature's of the crimes and
my the crimes the crime scene might be
totally contaminated and and this guy
might have been a fan yeah those they
have those it's just yeah but so the
thing is it's like so they don't really
know if that was the guy he's dead
so they'll never catch him so I don't
know if this is ever gonna be solved
because like I said if the FIR if they
think if let's say that he was 35 years
old in 1971 you know how old he would be
really old now or dead I got a feeling I
got a feeling it wasn't him
okay he was just some weirdo I got a
feeling that was a fan of the case of
the crimes yeah I don't believe the
devil I mean you can see why they didn't
arrest him because like I said it's not
illegal to be a weirdo that parks your
car where a body was found earlier
chances are was a guy Connell it kind of
like D'Angelo he was married and you
know has a fam had a family like rape
and he just blended it he blended right
in and in fact he did that [ __ ] and
never went back to the scene you know
and something you know groupies did like
that guy but he didn't that's what I
think that's so weird serial killer
bourbon that fits the more that that
fits more the pattern of usually what
happens yeah usually it's a comic reader
or a guy like D'Angelo which is really
scary man cuz you can't have family yeah
and then or carry which okay Gary
Ridgway you know I mean they have a
families and they have wives and you
know Ridgeway went back but not to go
[ __ ] around like that wrench which
Ridgeway went back to go get him some
weed weed weed you know he'd go back to
getting some of that rotten stank
yeah problem we keep bringing that dude
up cuz he's just so [ __ ] gross and
it's like well the thing about him to
and the wood Gary Ridgway was the lowest
maggot you could ever [ __ ] yeah
Jake maggot it made it made me think
when you were talking about the keys and
you were talking about how
you know once you kill a lot of people I
wouldn't know but it's like once you
kill a lot of people wanted together
yeah and I was thinking of Gary Ridgway
and I'm like how the [ __ ] did that dude
keep track of everything I don't think
he did he didn't care really maybe not I
have like a minute man I can't even keep
track of like where all my spare glasses
are I think he remembered them you know
because he could answer some questions
but I think he got confused a lot about
smarter details ablai he just kind of
had vague vague recollections like I
said unless he had some like [ __ ] OCD
or something like that and could
remember every detail perfectly I don't
think Ridgeway was big into that maybe
he was I mean the thing about I don't
think he was from what I remember he was
does he I don't like it I was like okay
yeah but he didn't have like a
photographic memory about it he didn't
remember all their names and would
forget where he put some of them
sometimes and which like I said he
killed a lot of people's you know that's
understandable and like I said it's so
funny cuz he's just this weaselly
Weasley little [ __ ] maggot of a man
yeah you know I mean the coward in front
of the police just you know he was
cowardly because it's like he gets got
him like what did you think was gonna
yeah I mean you thought we were just
gonna let you run around and do that or
yeah the cops would you know the cops
said that it was funny they'd raised
they'd raised their voice around him and
he would just [ __ ] cowering oh oh
well that's all these dudes are kind of
like that why they're always like
picking on women and prostitutes and
stuff like that I don't think you I
don't think he was very violent with
them I think he just he wasn't very
tough yeah I mean wouldn't surprise me
if they could beat his ass I think that
he just I would have paid to see that I
think he just somehow gods no he she got
him running back from the back and just
strangled him oh yeah you probably like
[ __ ] snuck up on him cuz like you
said if they like try it if he tried to
like come at you like from the front
they probably tried his ass kick him in
the balls was not not he was not
physically intimidating at all just kind
of weaselly but he had that
serial-killer creep
yeah our yeah the thing about BTK though
was that I think the reason that he
remembered [ __ ] so well was because I
mean particularly and from reading that
book that Sophie sent me which gave me a
lot of
insight into his bizarre thought
processes was that he spent so much time
I mean he called the people that he
killed and stuff like that he called
them projects now he didn't kill all of
the people that he had projects but yet
[ __ ] tons of projects and he always had
like at least one going sometimes
several but he had like [ __ ] detailed
notes and drawings yeah and all kind of
[ __ ] so he planned [ __ ] he got off on
the planning yeah that was all but that
was his foreplay
that's why yes so that's why I think for
you know why he could go without killing
for such a long time period not just
because he had other family [ __ ] going
on cuz I think there was like a big gap
like when his kids were born and he was
saying you know I was busy with my job
and my wife and my kids and I was happy
and I wasn't thinking about it but then
like when he would go out of town for
work then he would start thinking about
it but he really got off on just
thinking about how he was gonna do it
you know what I mean and sometimes he
would just like spend months and months
like working on one project or PJ as he
called it and he would just spend months
and months working on that but he would
never kill the person can you [ __ ]
imagine like finding out like years
later that you were one of his [ __ ]
projects I'm sure some did yeah I'm sure
they did
I mean when it all came out because he
confessed all that [ __ ] was in the book
and everything and it's like you
wouldn't even know just like this
[ __ ] creepy ass [ __ ] like
following you around everywhere and like
drawing [ __ ] you know maps of your
house and like figuring out how he was
gonna break in and all this other crap
and it's like holy [ __ ] [ __ ] man
I can't imagine because I was I was
listening to this thing the other day of
about people who had escaped serial
killers like they didn't know but then
like later on they found out like people
that had you know been hitchhiking and
they got picked up by [ __ ] ed Kemper
or whatever cuz you know he would do
that like he would pick up a bunch of
people and that he didn't kill him so I
you know so I was listening to a bunch
of that kind of [ __ ] I'm like can you
[ __ ] imagine I don't know it's not it
but I would never feel safe ever again
what gonna happen to me I'm not I'm not
scared of serial killers most of them
there's really only one of them that I
want two of them now but considered to
be put in the realm a badass and that
would have been D'Angelo was one of his
cop D'Angelo could take a couple and if
he [ __ ] challenged him he'd come find
you that was he
some [ __ ] guts balls and he had snot
in a good way and he had some physical
prowess the rest of them are cowards you
know well like I said that's kind of why
you know a lot of them just pick on
people women luminarias yes little women
it's like they'll pick up or people they
perceive as easy targets cuz obviously
not everybody is there was a couple
badasses back in the old days like the
dude that would just rape everybody rape
all the men on the train back in here
the night I'll pan carl panzram he was a
[ __ ] badass that's he was but he was a
badass
he was just like it's terrible terror
yeah he was a badass of the early 1900s
though I don't know how well he would
have done in the 20th century in the
late 20th century 21st century he was
just like a rabid dog that is he was
pretty tough compared to his sucker
contemporaries everything he learned in
prison you know pulled a gun on ioan
[ __ ] rape he's only raped men just
raping men weird it's like not young boy
yeah I think cuz we did that show about
him and it's like not even like he just
want he just he was a power power rapist
yeah well I think that I mean I think
pretty much all rapists are yeah I mean
that's kind of like the ultimate leather
daddy but not in a good way
and what was fine he didn't have any
concept of gay or anything I don't even
think he realized he was gay well that's
what I mean I don't think that I don't
even know if that like entered anyone's
mind it was just like a it was just like
a power in humiliation
yeah full of power in humiliation that
was his sexual orientation that it was
only sex that he knew I don't he had no
interest in women not really I think he
only just man yeah weird [ __ ] and he
just really he really did not give a
single [ __ ] about anything or anyone or
rape and killed little boys and
everything yeah little kids he didn't
give a [ __ ] no he just hated all mankind
he just hated everybody he would just
[ __ ] kill you and throw you over the
boat and feed you to alligators yeah it
like kind of understandable you know I
mean from an early kid or from an early
age is kid growing up in a damn
orphanages in prisons and sexual abuse
from an early age and been raped from
early age by men and he just grew up to
be a just looking rape monster which you
know and we talk about that a lot too
it's like I know that there is some
you know there is some genetic factor in
people that end up like that because
like I said a lot of people have had
terrible childhoods and turned out
fairly okay like it turned out not
serial killers at least or at least had
like a normal productive life
but you know it doesn't help it doesn't
help when you have these [ __ ] because
I feel like when you raise people like
that and that's all they know I mean it
takes a lot to get past that you know
what I mean that that if that's all you
know is just hatred and violence and
yeah you know and that's how you you
just learned that that's how you treat
people
yeah panzram was kind of like a
prototype an even worse version of of a
british prisoner called charles bronson
yeah that was a great movie it's just
called it's called bronson and it's
single bronson yeah yeah if you guys
want if you like clockwork orange' see
Bronson somebody sent it to us that
[ __ ] is badass
that's a [ __ ] badass he was another
one that just like crazy yes [ __ ] with
British prisoner who just he's really
famous within the UK he's very famous
yeah because it's weird I don't know
about now it is but like when I was
there that there is some kind of like in
British culture there is like a romantic
I guess of romanticizing of a certain
type of British criminal you know what I
mean not necessarily murders murderers
but gangsters bank robbers that kind of
thing but kind of do it here I guess
they do that in the u.s. kind of tale
yeah but it is kind of like cuz it's
almost kind of like he's getting one
over on the man type of thing maybe
that's what it is most of it here you
know would have been like the Italian
gangsters and you know what the mob yeah
cuz I guess we kind of romanticized them
yeah that's not the way that we're just
like oh they're awesome but it's Old
West outlaws yeah we always like to like
watch stuff about them even though
they're blowing people's heads off and
that's not cool but you know what I mean
a lot of that stuff's happening in the
criminal underworld though there are no
innocent people in the criminal law code
that's maybe and so it's like it's kind
of different when you're going in there
just like mowing down a bunch
like schoolchildren and nuns or
something like that but if you're just
like shooting another gangster
everyone's like knit yeah trash took
itself out
I guess so we're not worried about it
well it's two warring armies yeah so I
guess it's like you know you can kind of
seat your bloodlust a little bit do not
feel too bad about a kiss the people
that take old kind of suck tail do you
worry about it
alright so we're already at an hour so I
think we will take a break refill drinks
do whatever it is that we have to do and
when we come back we're gonna talk about
a rare female serial killer an Italian
serial killer Leonarda Cianciulli
otherwise known as the soap maker of
correct yeah yeah and you can probably
imagine why she's called that but look
into that after the break so we'll be
back in just a couple of minutes what
you doing
look at this button look at your button
it's always waving around always waving
around yeah oh my god yes oh the feet
yeah yeah you love Mama's feet for some
reason I don't know why oh she loves
mommy's arm too what you're trying to
get the elbow yeah I know I know but
sticking up their little butt sticking
up oh you're just gonna chill out there
yeah all right
you love true crime I love true crime
and I've spent the last three years
compiling a series of the most
intriguing unsolved murders of the 20th
century it's called the faceless villain
and volume three is available now
featuring such fascinating cases as the
Caddy murders the carry babies case the
Frog Boys the al-qasr murders and the
inokashira park dismemberment incident
the faithless villain volume three is an
involving exploration of unsolved slang
spanning the years from 1980 to 1999
pick up your copy and prey
or eBook formats on Amazon or download
the audiobook version from audible.com
and get ready for a chilling journey
through modern crime history
all right we're back
I got refilled it I put about that much
vodka that Skyy Vodka in there and
filled the rest of it up with that Sam's
lemonade man that shit's good he's
drinking my pocket
well yeah it's like I have a I have a
screwdriver and I tasted that and I was
like man that's so good I'm gonna have
one of those next yeah oh my god I
forgot you bought that big thing
eliminated yeah today got two of I love
lemon vodka
they were cheap yeah that's just one in
it I thought a good I think you just got
just one yeah I can't remember if it was
the one that was like you together it's
like almost a gallon yeah it was like
two dollars
Sam's that [ __ ] yeah been really good
that's what we do cuz we buy so much cuz
I like vodka and like I said vodka goes
with anything should I still got some
zing Zang in there I need to make a
little one of these days but uh you can
buy any kind of fruit juice and it
tastes good yeah we got two big things
at apple juice I got a big thing orange
juice got a big thing a [ __ ] lemonade
give a grape juice it's good with
anything yeah that's why that goes with
anything that's a nice thing Sheila
tequila's gotta be real careful with it
well yeah because tequila's kind I don't
like to kill us but I know people like
and I'm not [ __ ] on you or anything
like that but it is funky tasting and
it's kind of uh she said it funky taste
funky taste it depends on what you get
yeah silver tequila is very close to
vodka with it vodka with a Wang you say
Mugabi you say that but it's like every
time but it's funny because he's one of
these people that make you taste it yeah
it's like even though I'm like look I
don't like tequila it all tastes like
tequila today it's like nothing I've
ever tasted taste didn't taste like
tequila yeah even though he's like you
can't even taste the tequila and I'm
like you are high because that tastes
exactly like tequila so some tequila you
can't mix like that real nice stuff that
Sophie sent me yeah I forgot what I
forgot what flavor that was yeah but
that [ __ ] kind of had like a habanero
flavor to it yeah the only thing that it
was good with was orange juice yeah but
it was best like kind of like on its own
well yeah some [ __ ] cuz this never did
they tell you that they say you know
that expensive gold and represent a kilo
you don't want to mix
yeah I mean this em wall is good mixing
scotch you know you don't mix good yeah
there's certain kind of alcohol if you
pay enough for it you're just gonna
drink it by itself and [ __ ] sip that
[ __ ] but you know that she I just buy
Skyy Vodka that's like those 20 bucks or
that big huge body yeah or Samsa FICA
which is only which I can't tell you're
doing scat with Sam's that same we were
talking about that before we turn the
recorder on him like the nice thing
about vodka is that once you get over
like the $10 price point no they're all
pretty good yeah like I have had shitty
vodka yeah like if you get mr. cracker
mr. crowd I think it's the one cuz
that's like the house liquor like at
some bars like downtown and stuff oh and
if you get that that it's like drinking
paint thinner by rubbing alcohol yeah
it's really really bad but like over $10
like even pinnacle is passable like if
you mix it with [ __ ] and some of the
flavors are actually pretty good I think
bar price on aristocrat is probably like
four or five bucks a [ __ ] fifth I
think that shit's [ __ ] dislike it is
chase we should ask a big dump it runs
me yeah it's Domino I don't know if he
uses that as this house vodka yes no no
he mostly has the good he has good stuff
even as absent and he doesn't even
really charge that much for it
yeah the prices in there recently and
although I have to say the prices at
independent bar also very reasonable
considering like some other bars and
some other cities I've been to they're
like hugely expensive yeah I mean you
know okay we gotta get to the soap lady
the soap lady
they call it was soap lady cuz you know
she making people out of soap probably
made it she made cakes to human cakes
yeah damn good so you know this this
woman is interesting to me because she
doesn't have like I guess I'm fascinated
with female serial killers just because
there's not as many but also male serial
serial killers tend to fall into you
know your sexual sadist kind of thing
not usually a lot of variation in motive
they generally do yeah they do generally
do seem like mostly sexual sadist some
of them have some other weird motives
but not usually female ones seem to be
kind of all over the map and this woman
she didn't kill a
hell of a lot of people but only just
because she got caught you know fairly
early on at her core you shouldn't start
till she was probably in her 30s but her
rationale for doing it was very strange
and maybe like unprecedented so this
this woman is named Leonarda Cianciulli
now she was born in 1894 oh [ __ ] in an
Italian province called Montella which
apparently is very well known for
growing chestnuts so there's that
now chin nuts I suppose yes or truck
nuts
hey better I'm sure they probably sell
them at a cracker you Europe waiters you
don't know what truck nuts are some
trucks on the back Oh nuts hanging dudes
put [ __ ] balls hanging on the back of
the car yeah they're like wait they're
not okay so you don't need to trailer
hitch yeah they're they're not like
they're plastic right but they're flat
yeah but they're flat well they're flat
but then they're like three dimensional
on this side you know what I'm saying
they're not like anatomically correct
truck has just hit the truck hasn't
thought of that
some do this a minute trucks got balls
man and then they put a facility that
makes them balls and it just became it
and then people bought them yeah it
wasn't original though you know I mean
cuz uh Roman emperors had [ __ ] nuts
hanging off the front of their [ __ ]
chariots when they would do a triumph do
a triumph through the town years yes
yeah we're gonna put Dixon ballsy on
that body it's America America really is
the modern and modern rivers in Rome
pretty much in every way put some
[ __ ] balls even now even a poor
country man can have balls hanging off
the [ __ ] back of his truck and then
back is just like a Roman is like a
Roman Emperor
it's democratized I like that after all
time I don't even know now I want to
like delve into the history of truck
nuts because I'm like kind of interested
I haven't seen him in a while like I
used to see him cuz I grew up in Daytona
Beach which is like there might be a
redneck Riviera
but uh yeah Riviere yeah yeah um you
know what I mean so they sold them in
[ __ ] Pep Boys yeah and as a
performance modification yeah yeah they
were just like on the thing just with
all the like you know
[ __ ] [ __ ] scented yeah things you hang
on your thang you'd say the same [ __ ]
they put crowns in the back windows back
in the [ __ ] Louis Thank You class
back in the 90s at crowns the let'em I
like the little credit they descended
from Kings yeah you have royalty in your
car that's right the [ __ ] boomerang
coming off the back trunk yeah I know
you dudes remember that back when they
have cell phones had it [ __ ] have a
boomerang attack with that movie that we
saw the other day that had the [ __ ]
[ __ ] man now I can Trevor I love all
those old money buddy there was a dude
like that in Escape from New York right
like the Duke of New York that has yes
yeah and I was like man I would seven
have had that car in the 70s I know I'm
white but you know what I mean it's like
that when I was in your carpet all over
the inside yeah I'm like that's [ __ ]
awesome what are you talking about
Beckett I was in your army had guys in
the [ __ ] company in hundred first if
I could had their cars all decked out
not only what with fake cell phone in
the car
back in the 90s back when a real cell
phone was expect-- wasn't really
expensive so they would have [ __ ]
postal kind of giant yeah there was one
time called the Showboat his name the
car and it went through several hands
and it had showboat on the back [ __ ]
window just like a [ __ ] Cutlass
Cutlass Capri or something you know and
it's a showboat often imitated never
duplicated it had the [ __ ] boomerang
and ten on the back and up in on the
center console down on the bottom had a
push-button telephone a real telephone
not a cell phone just a push-button
telephone it was like something out of a
Rudy ray Moore flick man it was fake
yeah and the guy the guy that can't
remember his name man Oh shucks
hysterical he was so [ __ ] funny he
had a fake cell phone he carried around
see now remember those yeah you could
put batteries in it we'd call him on it
he'd start laughing like oh man I didn't
he'd be he's standing there with a cell
phone up against his head remember those
back in 93 you're important they're
super important and it [ __ ] it even
lit up but it just had batteries to
light the [ __ ] it's just to light the
buttons up can you imagine
going in a store and buying that yeah
how yeah how small of a dick do you have
to have it was well and another thing
too it was early 90s you don't mean what
I hope in a steward was that done who
did they think that was impressing
though the girls I guess um China member
is now that is erroneous I'm trying to
remember his name no no woman I've ever
known in my whole entire life has ever
been if his name was brown his last name
was brown by someone fake self or a real
cellphone even back in the days when
that many people not that many people
had them everyone's like look at that
douche yelling hated that cellphone
private for an [ __ ] private first
class brown and [ __ ] this was during
the time with [ __ ] criss cross was
big on the [ __ ] crib ever criss cross
yeah with the backward backward [ __ ] he
would wear his [ __ ] backwards [ __ ]
hat backwards [ __ ] when he was down
right when he was downrange you know I
mean everybody you know and he had the
fake cellphone and would stand on the
[ __ ] corner with traffic going by
right in front of the club's that we all
used to go to pretended like he was
talking on the fake [ __ ] a cell photo we
called brown brown that's a fake self
already put the cell phone I was right
in the middle of a caller you guys are
so good she was [ __ ] funny I was like
that kind of stuff is like baffling to
me cuz I don't know I don't know like
how Brad was hanging out the barracks
one time he his girlfriend with him and
I pulled up on that [ __ ] 600 ninja
was putting it up and she ran up to me
she just oh can you take him for a ride
real quick and I looked at Brown he goes
yeah take it for a ride yeah he was [ __ ]
it lady
he was [ __ ] ass I got her on her back
and run around the block and [ __ ]
hopefully nothing handed on a moving
motorcycle no the army was a strange
[ __ ] place and and and the women that
were attracted by the army were strange
[ __ ] women but we're all strange in
our own ways now that was back in the
day back in the day the barracks wasn't
what barracks was a wonderful place
at Fort Campbell yeah yeah all right so
I don't even know how we got off on that
Oh truck nuts now I needed we should do
a whole show about the history of truck
nuts yeah I like that they later started
doing like different races so I thought
that was kind of neat because I only
ever saw white people jerk nuts
yeah although I know white that was a
white thing I was gonna say I don't know
why why anyone have any other base would
what [ __ ] I don't want that why it's
like but it was like I said I grew up in
Daytona Beach it was a competition
between redneck men yeah and their
trucks and their and yeah cuz they had
like the big huge truck that were so big
it's like you can even get into it
without a [ __ ] stepladder which to me
seems like it would be although you know
some people may I don't want to talk
about this what are you feeling
triggered right now no I still won't
fall into stereotypes are you feeling
attacked well I you know I don't there's
always this [ __ ] there's always this
[ __ ] idea out there that the bigger
the truck the more a man is trying to
compensate yeah that's that's the common
perception sure the biggest monster
truck I've ever [ __ ] seen okay pulled
up at start at a Starbucks one time this
is about three years back I was on my
[ __ ] bule's up there right and I was
just this gigantic [ __ ] monster truck
was huge and the door open and I was
thinking what kind of [ __ ] rednecks
in this thing door opened up and a
[ __ ] Japanese guy came out of it oh
my god that's very funny yeah I don't
think I've ever like a Japanese American
I think I've ever seen a Japanese person
yes sir Chuck Hebrew they just seemed
like they'd be today I'm like musical
where the head part that fit your garage
it's like it won't fit like in a parking
garage like what the [ __ ] and I could
tell by what he was wearing he I think
he was ex-military you know because
there's kind of like clothes in the
hamster trucks yeah I feel like well the
compensation thing kind of came in to I
was like well I you do have to wonder
about somebody that's making that
ostentatious and display the [ __ ]
truck what a matter what it is [ __ ]
she
I mean that's the thing that I'm
thinking of is that I don't know if it's
a small dick necessarily but you've got
to be compensating for something
it had a ladder to get into it that's it
okay here let me back up here in Florida
there's no restrictions on this [ __ ]
your [ __ ] can yeah you can have the most
ridiculous you could [ __ ] on a tank
okay
little it's yes you can have whatever
you want nobody will [ __ ] with you over
anything here and my motorcycles
technically probably don't pass a lot of
[ __ ] specifications the cops don't
give a [ __ ] about that hear things like
mirrors and how the distance between
blinkers and [ __ ] the way the way
license plates are mounted is if there's
a license plate on it they're happy yeah
there's like what it gives you okay well
these trucks get out of [ __ ] hand
this truck had a ladder descendant
underneath the damn door to get into it
it must have six rungs on that [ __ ]
ladder yeah I've seen ones like that I
mean like why would you do that to
yourself
I don't know man like why would you wait
life is enough of a pain in the ass like
why add one extra pain in the ass and
just further thing was it wasn't really
a truck it was more like a [ __ ]
Humvee like a giant monster Humvee you
know I mean I'm not a truck kind of guy
but it didn't have a bed like a try it
might have been a gigantic Range Rover
or a giant each I get except it's just a
gigantic [ __ ] I think it might have
been a Hummer
yeah but the wheels were five and a half
feet tall baby
so taller than me yeah top of the wheel
you know super practical [ __ ] right
what the hell where can you take that I
don't know you know you took it to
Starbucks that's where they're all
taking yeah is that like I said I grew
up in Daytona and it's like just one
time cuz there were a few people that
live there that had this big gigantic
like ostentatious ridiculous like
redneck Mobile's that were like [ __ ]
gigantic just one time I wanted to see
one of those trucks pull up in front of
the
I can ranch it which was the most
popular club in Daytona when I was
growing up and the dude open the door
and then he just falls right out flat on
his face and like the fringe goes flying
his mullet the goes flying you know I
mean that would have been so so funny
and that would've been like the funniest
thing that I ever saw but I never got to
see that no like I was driving past
there I'll put snot but you know you
guys are you guys that don't live here
in Florida you're [ __ ] missing out
there's some [ __ ] you can see I mean you
know it's kind of boring in our
neighborhood but it's you know Tiger
Kings style [ __ ] happening down here
yeah yeah that's the thing like Tiger
King happened here well some of it did
and like most of that should happen in
like Oklahoma or wherever the [ __ ] it
was but it's like I know people like
that yeah
so it's night it was crazy but imagine
you take those people and you give them
money yeah and then no good can come up
yeah you give them money and then you
don't [ __ ] then you like take all the
laws away and just you know there's laws
but it's like they're not enforce the
important laws you can't kill people you
can't steal other than that you do the
[ __ ] you want pretty much oh yeah you
know as long as they'll just kind of
they don't even really care about drug
today I don't even really care about
drugs depending on what it is I don't
know what you're doing yeah largely your
left your end of it
yeah they don't really care this is not
an authoritarian country I mean like I
said as long as you're not like going
out like [ __ ] mowing people down or
anything yeah they don't care they don't
really care about gun laws if you're
just like sitting in your house you know
yeah drop an asset or something like
yeah not give a single [ __ ]
honestly all right so uh again truck
nuts cut just yeah extracted us well
that was an interesting topic I know and
now I'm like really interested I'm gonna
have to look up we have to they should
do it hanging American culture to the
world we're explaining and everyone's
just like no thank you yes next I'm
gonna order some truck nuts just so we
can like show on the show next time yeah
but yeah put some truck nuts on the back
of a [ __ ] Ford Taurus
I'm dragging like five thousand four two
thousand four children dragging on the
[ __ ] ground as you're driving
it's got balls pull up to look and see
if you had a mullet now I'm gonna have
to get it because you can't you have to
have those two things together like you
can have truck nuts and not have a
moment so one of us is gonna have to get
a mullet with a mullet probably gonna
have to be a man [ __ ] put her in
[ __ ] cut-offs for the bikini top
[ __ ] titties a [ __ ] makes sense okay
even though even though it's an old
silver rusty silver yeah yeah yeah have
your hair tied back in the pot and then
we have a [ __ ] 40 ounce and your
[ __ ] hand way driving big big tall
boy in Louisiana if you when I was in
Louise when I lived in Louisiana if you
weren't drinking and driving there was
something [ __ ] wrong I figured drink
and drive there well I feel like when
when I was in the UK in the 90s that was
kind of like it was technically you
weren't supposed to you were supposed to
be everyone just kind of did it yeah
beer in hand you know what I mean
Louisiana's law I mean I never saw
anybody getting caught for it never was
just like yeah whatever
buy at least when I was in a while yeah
that's hilarious
but yeah you'll get in trouble for that
[ __ ] here but yeah so anyway so let's go
back to the serial killing
yeah it's get the show over with like I
do like those people like the sidetracks
you know what I mean yeah they're
entertaining makes the show longer
people like that out yeah we're bad now
the runtime yeah I think even though we
don't have to it can be as long as I
want but yeah so we're talking about
Leonarda Cianciulli all right so as I
said born in 1894 now she reportedly did
not have a very happy childhood growing
up now she I don't know like a lot of
the specifics but she for sure like
suffered from a lot of depression and
possibly anxiety when she was a teenager
she attempted suicide at least two times
now she did end up getting married in
1917 to a register
clerk named Raphael e-penser D now when
she got married apparently her mom
didn't like the guy and reportedly
cursed her now Leonarda was a very
superstitious young woman so she kind of
like believe all this kerschen and
everything like that she believed that
was real and that that her mother had
actually cursed her and that was gonna
like make her life be like [ __ ] up for
and there's been early 1900s it was yeah
okay this like I said she was born in
1894 so this is very very early 20th
century right now to add insult to
injury not only did she feel like she
was on the bad side of a curse from her
mom but over the course of her marriage
she got pregnant 17 times
that's a serial pregnancy woman which
she's a fertilis [ __ ] thank [ __ ] for
birth control that's all I can say yeah
children each time okay of the 17 times
she got married she got married
no no uh pregnant yeah she didn't she
didn't get married 17 times so she got
pregnant seventy times three of them
were miscarriages um ten of the children
were born but died when they were little
like all of them before the age of ten
so she did have four children that lived
so here's the thing now imagine that you
are a woman who's had one miscarriage or
one child died um that is very traumatic
obviously now multiply that by three
times for the miscarriage ten times for
the children dying and they were born
yes well some of them were like kids
like it was all before they were ten
years old but they weren't like babies
you know what I mean they sure she
wasn't killing them not that I ever
heard of good so that's a very high
mortality rate although Italy back in
the early 1900s was kind of I mean if
this was kind of a rural area - yeah so
I'm not
like how in this era era a lot of
Italians were running from Italy coming
to the United States so it may have the
living conditions may have not have been
that good that's what I mean it might
have been like poverty might have an
actor everything like that because
because Italians came here we call a
white [ __ ] they I respect a [ __ ] Hannah
[ __ ] [ __ ] love you [ __ ] and your
food [ __ ] in it at this stage I wish
I was Italian it's like American food
yeah it's like not even when Italians
came to the United States to see back in
the early 1900s dough to a land of
[ __ ] Plenty that [ __ ] cuisine just
[ __ ] blossomed it was like taking
Italian food and putting it on steroids
you know thought about I'm American
lasagna and American Pizza Chicago pizza
in New York Pizza [ __ ] it's all good
[ __ ] that's better than what they have
in Italy by our standards I haven't been
Italy by our standards you not I mean
and Italian Americans will tell you that
their food here is better than the food
back in the old country I mean I really
do feel like between like the Irish and
the Italians that really does seem like
yeah I mean they had a massive impact on
American culture well they came here and
they [ __ ] moved up a lot well mitten
the Irish it took him a while from the
car it all took everybody a while to
come up well you know just the way it is
but yeah like I said at this stage it's
kind of like Italian food is pretty much
synonymous with American food I mean
yeah we just can't get any more American
Italian food pizza or spaghetti or
anything like that even though I've seen
done even though in my lifetime I do
remember when Italian food was seen as
foreign still yeah I have a back in the
70s I have a whole body Crocker cookbook
from the very early like 1930 users yeah
my grandma had that book yeah that's a
great cookbook it'll tell you how to
make sour cream yeah it's been that big
it will tell you how to make [ __ ]
components and [ __ ] like that
and it hasn't it hasn't at a foreign
food section and Italian is in it yeah
it explains to you what oregano is
that's hilarious
that's the way it was back then oregano
is an exotic foreign thing and then when
it's chose to tells you how to make
spaghetti sauce I
if you were to try to execute that
there's just nothing to it yeah that's a
shitty recipe but that's the way it was
back then
well they didn't like there's really
nothing in it yeah everybody kind of
like their taste buds I guess would it's
like everybody like ever limited bland
bland anything that was too spicy
wiggled right it's kind of like I guess
kind of like that now like the Midwest
still has that you know I have a feeling
based on my studies the stuff that they
were having in Chicago back I like in
the in the Capone era back in the
[ __ ] italian-american Golden Age
that's not what they were eating they
were eating what basically what we're
kind of eating now it took a while for
that to really become mainstream yeah
like I said I still remember in the 78
allien food was still kind of considered
foreign yeah yeah yeah even though
nowadays I don't think anybody would
call it that no it's just but no it was
just getting any more American really
than Italian stuff that's what I mean
like I said they're particularly
particularly in you know food culture
it's really kind of infiltrate in the
America even the Northeast and the round
mess in Boston you know the [ __ ]
Italian neighborhoods we used to go to
those restaurants down there man that
[ __ ] food is so [ __ ] well yeah the
same in New York and it's like you know
what I mean they've I went to like Tanja
[ __ ] Italian restaurants pizza places
I can't remember man I went to a really
good one in [ __ ] goddamn I can't even
read where it is now but in New York
City like an Italian place era oh man it
was so [ __ ] good Italian Italian
Americans kind of they kind of cornered
the American game they knew how to they
knew how to [ __ ] become successful in
the United States well we love fat and
cheese they kept their ethnic identity
yeah yeah not so much like us Irish
generic generic generic well what are
you gonna do
but yeah so uh alright so where was I
alright so she had had ten children
that died three miscarriages so she did
have four children that survived into
adulthood
now it's thought that one of the
children when he was grown enlisting in
the Italian army uh at the time of World
War two and like you know going off to
fight in World War two might have been
the catalyst for her becoming a serial
killer because as I said she was very
superstitious and because she had lost
so many children she was very she was
kind of looking for any way to protect
her four remaining children from dying
because of what had happened to her in
the past so she went to let's call them
extreme measures
although bizarre measures to keep that
from happening now she did have a minor
criminal record stemming from 1927 she
was actually put in prison for fraud
that's I think she was in her early 30s
at that stage um so after she got out of
prison for that they moved to another
place Las adonia which wasn't far from
where she had grown up now in 1930 the
very famous or Pinilla earthquake hit
that particular part of Italy and their
family home was completely destroyed so
here's another thing there's another
like just a cherry on top of the [ __ ]
sundae that is her life or at least like
how she [ __ ] perceived it so since
her life was so shitty at least from her
point of view she decided she was going
to go to a fortune-teller now reportedly
this fortune-teller looked at her hands
you know like they do the [ __ ] hand
breathe into the hands lines of your
hands and stuff like that and said and I
quote in your right hand icy prison in
your left a criminal asylum how true
that is I don't know but spoiler alert
that's how that worked out so here's
what happened so when her son said that
he was going to his name was giuseppe
said he was going to enlist in the army
and go off to world war ii she kind of
wigged out a little bit because like I
said she only had four
laughter all her other ones had died and
she was kind of like really sensitive
about it so she decided to go to extreme
lengths to protect him in her
superstitious way from dying so she
decided that the only way to do that was
human sacrifice mmm I'm not really sure
where this idea came from like why you
got this idea is not Italian culture
this is some bull yeah and that's what a
lot of people pointed out that was like
some they're like 'no that's not
sanctioned by roman catholicism that is
not sanctioned by any other religion or
belief system that was going this was
just a weird idea that she got in her
head that she decided this is witchcraft
yeah that yeah I kind of feel like this
is kind of like a back because she did
believe in like curses and fortune
tellers and all that kind of stuff so I
do think that she maybe thought well
this is like a big deal like God or
whoever has taken all my other kids and
this is one of the only kids I got left
and I really don't want him to get
killed so he must want me to do
something really big and splashy to like
keep him from getting killed so that was
apparently what her idea was so she
decided she was gonna have to sacrifice
a human so the first person that she
killed was a woman named Foust Tina
Sethi now she was a spinster that lived
in the same town as her so what she did
was she invited Foust Tina over because
she was like hey um she was acting kind
of like a matchmaker type of thing she's
like I'm gonna set you up with a husband
so why don't you come over to my house
she had vows Tina write a whole bunch of
letters to her family members saying
that you know oh my friend Leonarda has
hooked me up with this guy and he lives
abroad and I'm gonna go visit him so she
wrote she wrote all these letters like
believing it and then Leonardo sent them
out
now when Faustina comes over to the
house Leonarda gives her a big old glass
of drugged wine
and then when she falls asleep she kills
her with an axe hmm then she cut fast
Tina's body into nine pieces and got all
the blood in the big tub Big Basin after
she was arrested this is what she said
that she did to phallus Tina she said
and I quote I threw the pieces into a
pot added seven kilos of caustic soda
which I had bought to make soap and
stirred the mixture until the pieces
dissolved in a thick dark mush that I
poured into several buckets and emptied
into a nearby septic tank as for the
blood in the basin I waited until it had
coagulated dried it in the oven ground
it and mixed it with flour sugar
chocolate milk and eggs as well as a bit
of margarine kneading all the
ingredients together I made lots of
crunchy tea cakes and served them to the
ladies who came to visit though Giuseppe
and I also ate them damn she's kind of
crazy [ __ ] craziest [ __ ] you little bit
you don't need any of that to [ __ ]
get rid of the body nor to making you
that food this is like I was like a
ritualistic it's just some kind yeah
she's definitely coming at it from Erb
ritualistic superstitious she's [ __ ]
crazy type of oh my goodness Buki just
came to Kitty's come see us she's been
sleeping all afternoon coz it's raining
outside so she was like I don't know
it's a rainy day yeah it is now she also
Leonarda also took I thought this was
kind of said Faustina's life savings
which were at the time three thirty
thousand italian lira which sounds like
a lot right seventeen dollars and thirty
nine cents well actually in today's
money that's three hundred and twenty
dollars which still not a lot that's
that's probably about what my but that
was the payment she had got four likes
for doing the matchmaking [ __ ] so she
kept that as well so she did get a
little bit of a payout but it does seem
to me like you said because she went to
all the trouble of
cutting up the body and drying out the
blood and like because that's a lot of
effort and then making them into cakes
and all this other kind of [ __ ] it
really does seem like there was a
ritualistic component because she said
not know that's just practice right not
only did she feed them to the neighbors
but her and her husband also ate them
now I'm not real clear on whether her
husband Giuseppe knew that she was doing
this [ __ ] and knew that he was eating
neighbor tea cakes with blood and that
maybe he didn't maybe he didn't know I
mean maybe he was at home I don't know
I'm not gonna I never saw anything that
said he knew anything about it
so he's like wow these are [ __ ]
delicious it's just like [ __ ] Sweeney
Todd yeah so September 5th 1940 she
kills her second victim this is a woman
named Francesca swabby now this was the
same kind of situation where this was a
woman who kind of lived alone she wasn't
married she was you know kind of a
spinster type woman that lived in the
area um in this case Leonarda told her
oh I have a job for you teaching abroad
and she did the same thing she like made
Francesca write all these letters to her
family members and say hey I'm going
abroad to teach and blah blah blah so no
one would come questioning like when she
didn't turn up and show like that so
Francesca comes to the house and she
gives her drugged wine and does the same
thing cut her up baked her into tea
cakes and took her savings now
sorry Pookie's like she's chewing he's
issuing on the table she wants to chew
on things I don't know what the deal is
making all that noise
okay she's like she look at me like what
I'm just doing what poki do hmm now her
next victim you know if she had just
done the first two she might have gotten
away with it because she picked two
women that were kind of isolated like
their families lived elsewhere they
lived alone they didn't have like a lot
of family in the area and stuff like
that so maybe she could have gotten away
with it however the third victim that
she picked was probably kind of a stupid
move because this woman was a woman
named Virginia ketchup oh now this woman
was not super famous but she
kind of well-known she was like a opera
singer a soprano and she had actually
sung at La Scala and stuff like that so
she wasn't a nobody like she was a
little bit of a celebrity now what
Leonardo did in this situation was that
she told Virginia that she's like oh I
got you this job with this like opera
guy or like an impresario or something
like that in Florence and so I you know
come over so we can set up all the
details and all this other kind of crap
so Virginia comes over on September 30th
1940 and that's what the first two
victims Virginia was fed spiked wine and
then killed with an axe now not only did
Leonardo make tea cakes out of the
woman's blood she also decided she was
gonna branch out a little bit and use
Virginia's fat to make soap hence her
name the soap maker of Courage II oh now
this is this is what she's in this is a
direct quote from her [ __ ] trial
Leonarda says she ended up in the pot
like the other two her flesh was fat and
white when it had melted I added a
bottle of cologne and after a long time
on the boil I was able to make some most
acceptable creamy soap
I gave bars to neighbors and
acquaintances the cakes too were better
that woman was really sweet she's crazy
this is a crazy woman I mean probably
not surprisingly like she has like a
terribly tragic life and everything but
still crazy yeah I mean I feel like if
this is if this woman had been
transplanted to now and like all these
horrible things that happened to her
like with all the children dying and
like all the [ __ ] whatever I feel
like she probably just would have gotten
psychiatric help it probably wouldn't
have killed anybody but I do believe
that because of the circumstances she
went crazy where yeah she just kind of
went off the deep end clearly and
decided I'm gonna make cakes and soap
out of people because that's a thing
that you do yeah there's no motive teeny
there's not and that's well that's what
I find so fascinating about her because
like I said a lot of male serial killers
you know it's sexual sadism
that's usually the motive a you know 99%
of the time whereas female serial
killers in this case is cannibalism and
making soap and superstition because she
really seemed to genuinely think that
doing these kind of ritualistic killings
was going to save her son from getting
killed
yeah in battle which I mean like I said
she really did seem to believe that
because she believed the gypsy curse she
believed her mom's curse she believed
all that [ __ ] like as far as I could
determine so she really did seem to be
delusional in this sense that I don't
know if she got any particular enjoyment
out of killing the women I think it was
just in a weird way it was like a
practical dessert she thought it was
bread that's what I'm saying they're
like from her perception it was
practical which I know it's like a very
[ __ ] weird thing to think about I'm
just gonna [ __ ] explain it one phrase
that we've used many times on this
[ __ ] show [ __ ] be crazy [ __ ] be
crazy
I don't know considering that 90% of
serial killers are men I think that men
do this I don't think the husband knew I
think it doesn't nothing I've seen like
suggest that he knew anything about it
although he had to be in the house when
all this is going on necessarily I mean
he might have taken that a job you did
yeah so he might miss out on yeah he may
have been out a lot that's some weird
[ __ ] and I mean it's not like she was
like killing people every day
it was quote-unquote only it was only
three women I can clean a deer make it
into just [ __ ] you know kitchen ready
pieces within about yeah 45 minutes
we'll see that's what I mean like okay
like you know hypothetically if I you
know went to work and it was like an
eight-hour workday or nine hours or
whatever with a commute like could you
could you do this kill a person and cut
them up and make cakes out of it before
I got home probably maybe you could yeah
probably and like clean rending or all
the components but what does she do with
the skeleton you know what I don't know
see there's gonna be skulls involved in
bones and you know where's all this
going maybe she's just like just tune it
out
and I guess you just threw her mouth I
mean maybe she just like threw him in
the back like you know how they used to
had just have [ __ ] you know the the
[ __ ] in the back where you just like
had the whole and yeah cuz I read it out
like den down the [ __ ] UH
outhouse yeah because I read about a
case one time where like a little boy
got murdered and they just like threw
him out the back of the [ __ ] cuz it
was just like a big hole like under the
outhouse or whatever and they just him
they didn't find him for like ages damn
you know what I mean so that's so the
thing about it is like I said and now
how'd she just kind of stuck to those
first two women that didn't really have
any family locally then she probably she
would have got away with it but the fact
that she killed this particular singer
Virginia she also had a sister and when
she got a letter from her sister
Virginia saying about all the [ __ ] that
she was doing she immediately thought it
sounded very fishy
so she um and I guess the sister kind of
lived close by too because she knew that
Virginia was going to Leonardo Chen
Chili's house that night so she
immediately reported the [ __ ] to the
police I mean she wasn't having it so
the cops go to lien artists house now
Leonarda initially is kind of like just
completely played innocent and
everything like that however it almost
seemed like the cops in this case we're
kind of like supernaturally astute
because they knew that I guess they knew
that lien artists one weakness was her
children because like I said she was
very very like overprotective over kids
because so many of them had died so the
four that she had left she was really
protective of them so what the cops told
her was that you know your son Giuseppe
he's gonna get arrested for these crimes
and then she immediately confessed that
it was her that did it so but you know
what I mean
right so so they at least knew that much
that she would cave if they like if they
said one of your beloved children is
gonna go down for this then they she
immediately like a [ __ ] confess to it
now she went on trial now the trial was
pretty short because I guess she had
confessed to it and she wasn't really
interested in hiding it anymore
now she got a 30 year she got 30 years
in prison and then three years in an
asylum which that's just what the gypsy
woman had said the Romanian woman
if it actually the fortune-teller yeah
I'm just saying that reportedly because
they were saying you know right hand
prison left hand and that's exactly how
it turned out she got thirty years in
prison and then she got transferred to a
mental hospital she lived the 30 years
she served she did in prison yep
she lived 30 years she got transferred
to the to the mental hospital for a
further three year sentence and then she
was going to be let out but she actually
died in the mental asylum not too long
before she's gonna be let out she didn't
die until 1970 actually she died of a
cerebral apoplexy hmm or like a
hemorrhage you know in the brain she was
79 years old oh [ __ ] well [ __ ] yeah
she'd have been too old to be in real
take care of herself and [ __ ] find a
job rehabilitate herself anyway true
yeah yeah so yes so she never got out
she actually died in the mental asylum
now interestingly and I said I have a
picture of this but they all of her um
stuff that she used like to make soap
and cakes and stuff out of her victims
like the axes and the pot and everything
that stuff was all donated to the
criminology Museum in Rome and as far as
I know it's still on display there
because I saw pictures of the display
and everything so you can actually see
the pots yeah axes that she used to like
I can do this [ __ ] and apparently I
don't know if there's been like other
movies based on her stuff like that but
there was actually a play called
love and magic in Mama's kitchen that
was based on her and it was it was first
put on in Italy in 1979 but then in 1983
they did a version for at the American
stage so it actually did play and
brought on Broadway in the 80s like in
the early way
Sweeney Todd yeah and that's exactly
what this reminded me of this is a very
Sweeney Todd esque
yeah kind of case but like I said that's
kind of what fascinates me which and we
should probably do more serial
killers we still need to do alien war
knows for Christ's sake because we
haven't even got around to doing her
somebody said that we should do when we
do Aileen Wuornos we should actually go
to Daytona and go to like the hotel
that's right here because it's like yeah
that's okay I went up there and did he
did yeah if you guys didn't see liked it
good this is Dan Bell like on YouTube
and he went to that I think it's the
hotel and he went to the bar and
everything like that because I know
where all that [ __ ] is that's where I
grew up and that's only probably about
30 40 miles from here yeah yeah it's
like a 20 minute drive yeah and like I
said that's only a few miles from where
I grew up and like I said I still lived
in Daytona when all that [ __ ] was going
on cuz I remember like before she got
caught and everything but I don't know
it's like so I do feel like in this
particular case it's just sort like a
really weird motivation I think this is
kind of one of the only cases like
serial killer cases that I've written
about or read about where this
apparently this particularly he's
definitely mentally ill well yeah
clearly this type of superstition was
like what spurred her because it's not
like she was a master criminal or she
started being a criminal like early she
didn't really start killing people until
she was in her 30s after she found out
that her son was joining the army like
apparently that freaked her out so bad
that she decided she was gonna start
sacrificing people to save him yeah and
you're not talking about you know sexual
sadism or [ __ ] sexual motives this is
[ __ ] mental illness and like I said I
think that's a case with a lot of
females here because would you see with
a lot of females here cuz other than
Aileen Wuornos who kind of had her own
thing going on but what you see with a
lot of them is they they seem to be one
thing they seem to kill people for
practical reasons you for money or they
seem to kill family members their
children their husbands things like that
they said they have like Munchausen by
proxy syndrome or you have the thing
where they're like nurses and they you
know Angel of Death Angel of Death type
killers they think they're killing
people because it's merciful yeah that
kind of thing so in that way it kind of
interests me more because their
psychology is more you know diverse I
guess
they have like some range low death
check kind of makes sense to me some of
it not all of it yeah I think how that
starts is is that they see a bunch of
people die suffering and dying they're
like well I'm gonna speed this up and
help this people help these people
yeah and it starts growing into where
they're killing people that aren't even
in danger of dying that's the thing
that's what I mean that's the night of
like you can get into a slippery slope
here I mean up to an extent it's like
you don't want to it particularly like
if you work somewhere like in a hospice
or something like that you see people
suffering and dying like every day and
it's like routine and I can see how you
would want to help you because no one
wants to see somebody else in that kind
of distress or see something like that
and you so you can see how you're like I
must speed this up yeah it's like it's
like man it's like they're not really
they're really not having a good time
and it's like you know maybe that it
would be merciful to do that in like to
an extent I can see that yeah but I
think after a while you kind of get in a
thing where it's almost like a power
thing yeah and the ones that got caught
were killing people that weren't in
danger time right I think it gets to a
point where even if they started out
with you know I guess you could call it
quote unquote good intentions or at
least you know their heart was in the
right place maybe but I think the more
that they do it I think it gets to a
point where they just you know their
their tolerance gets like bigger and
bigger and then and then I think they
start to enjoy the power that they have
with people it's like well I could leave
this person alive because I think she
just wandered out cuz you makes it makes
you wonder how many angel deaths are
actually out there there could be a lot
there might be a lot oh and that keep it
under control and right this person is
gonna die I've seen this a million times
imma [ __ ] take two care of this it's
probably a lot of that well I think
that's why and that might be a case I'm
not saying I don't think by any measure
that there are as many females or serial
killers as male but I'm saying that
there might be slightly more than they
think there are just because the women
don't get caught because of the way that
they go about it and the victim and the
victim is definitely terminal everybody
knows if it's an angel of death type
killer I can see how that would be very
very difficult to catch someone that was
doing that type of thing because it's
like these people are on death's door
anyway yeah and there may be a
professional agree
meant to wear [ __ ] everybody in the
damn hospitals goes like yeah that one's
a goner
[ __ ] yeah and then they you know I
mean we're yeah let's take care of that
I'm sure that [ __ ] happens I'm sure it
happens it yeah it wouldn't surprise me
cuz a lot of those professionals know I
mean I've you know like times business
got [ __ ] 18 hours I've been in a
couple of hospices in my time and I've
like and um cut my grandmother died in
one yeah and people that work there a
long time because I did talk to a few of
them and you know talk to some of them
online that work in that that field and
after a while you start to recognize
signs of when it's gonna happen like you
know what I mean they're not always a
hundred percent correct but they're
usually pretty accurate and I have to
say too
it's like I'm not sure how common this
is but I know there's more than one case
where you know how they'll bring in like
in a lot of hospices and stuff like that
they'll bring in like cats and dogs and
stuff like that like to chill the
residents out and stuff they all know
when it's and some of it some of the
cats like particular is one that's
famous but there's more than one um
where cats will know and they'll go sit
on that person's bed and then the next
day that personal dire like within X
hours that person will die like yeah and
it's like that all that [ __ ] always kind
of fasten it's like how the [ __ ] does
that cat know that it's must be some
kind of smell or you have a fantastic
sense of smell better do they know and
they can tell and they're an emotional
yeah emotional creatures they can read
and they go this was going you know I
can tell it I can tell this is gonna go
soon look go up and comfort the person
yeah because I I think I mean and like I
said even though I think a lot of people
have a perception that maybe cats aren't
as like affectionate as dogs or the way
they are it depends on the cat yeah but
I I mean I found particularly with you
know with with Pookie there yeah she is
a very affectionate cat if you're like
upset or you're like you know if you
wake up in the middle of night and some
of the she'll jump up and be like hey
man you are
and she'll like lay on your chest or lay
across your stomach for a little while
her and you know what a she's checks on
you if they know you they know the
situation they can read you yeah they
know when people are upset they know
when people don't feel good they know
you know what I mean it's like I think
it's more obvious with dogs but cats
will do it as well although I've seen
more I've seen more variety and behavior
of cats than dogs I think dogs are
pretty universally you know very human
centric whereas some cats are more human
centric than others dogs have a bigger
brain and there's something even though
they're goofy I think they are more
intelligent but cats casually present
two different kinds different kind of
intelligence yet and like I said I think
that's why I've always kind of I love
dogs but I've always been more a cat
person because I like that dogs to me
always came across as like a little
needy and it's like that's you're a
little more introverted yeah which like
I said I can I can relate to that
because it's more like my personality so
I kind of like that I don't want
somebody that's like up in my grill like
24/7 like wanting [ __ ]
but it's because dogs are pack animals
and cats aren't that's the big yeah I
mean when the dog when you have a dog
it's like that's you know you are their
human and like they always want to do
stuff to like please you and they're
always like hey interact with me hey do
this and that which you know which
Pookie does sometimes but sometimes she
just like man I just I want to go sleep
in my tree but she's the most
interactive cat that I've ever had in
the sense that when you're doing
something she just wants to follow you
were gonna be like hey what do you don't
know well with her it's all that eye
contact and body language
yeah she's communicating a lot she's a
she's a very communicative cat she is we
were [ __ ] going on by like cat
parents and [ __ ] I did the show wrap
that show up that's a good show are you
done I'm done with Sean [ __ ] loaded
I'm [ __ ] holding on I just told you
old Nagi brought that in at the break
and he's and he Blake before we started
the recording he's like I put this much
[ __ ] I'm like you are gonna be
incoherent but I'm hearing I'm holding
on just at the world's [ __ ] going by
I feel like I'm on a marry a good
merry-go-round a marier
merry-go-round yab hold I'm making here
item look later on what are you making
I'm gonna make some mom gonna make some
burger yeah I'm gonna make some [ __ ]
patty melts ohh
sound good and then on that potato bread
oh whoa yeah yeah look at all it's
working we're making everybody fat just
listen - yeah you want some bread you
want some crunchy tea cakes with some
dried blood
mMmmm I'm gonna saute onions there's a
bunch of [ __ ] I gotta do now now it's
like somebody should start well nobody
should start this please don't do this
but somebody should start - it's like a
lot of crunchy tea cakes that hopefully
and hardest yet you'll be a special yeah
I'm like oh it's got protein Friday
night is still sunny out yeah we
actually did this a little earlier than
you well cuz I told him it's like dude I
don't want to be up until like midnight
you call me dude ya know everybody it's
almost kind of like I'm not from
California but I just gotten that
because I say in California everyone's
dude yeah man woman do you girls are
doing it does it that's what I mean it
doesn't matter it's like it's not it's
not a gender term I kind of do that too
I kind of call everyone dude so you know
alright so we're gonna wrap up the show
about Italian serial killers hopefully
it was enjoyable I know we went off on a
lot of tangents but like I said you guys
seem to enjoy that so remember if you
like the show like share subscribe on
all your social media if you would like
to financially support the show be much
appreciated and go to our patreon page
patreon.com/lenguin
in the sidebar that goes to a PayPal
account if you'd like to give a one-time
donation like I said we will probably do
many more live streams yeah when I was
alive
alright so the next show we'll probably
do is a live stream and like I said we
still do matinees and the occasional
side tracks as live streams as well
because those seemed to be fun and like
I said less editing for me so that's a
win
yeah and like I said when we record
these we usually do them live anyway
because I hardly take anything out of
these and I don't think did I I didn't
mess up did I so ok I'm not taking
anything out of the show so this might
as well be a [ __ ] live on a [ __ ]
Tuesday actually they wouldn't mind
change it to a Saturday I don't care
ok I like I said it's you know
sometimes Saturdays you know after all
this pandemic should have sorted out
like we might be going out and show like
that feels like I just I like to have it
like on a regular schedule may known I'd
like to have a like on a fairly regular
schedule but like you said I did enjoy
doing that livestream and so we will at
least do one or two a month as a
livestream so you want to do the next
one is the livestream yeah why not okay
I don't even remember what the next oh I
know what it's gonna be
I'm going to go be I'm not gonna say all
right that's that's for like patrons to
like know cuz I always post like what
the next show is gonna be like on the
page you can do it on a Friday or a
Saturday you mean whatever yeah it did
seem like most people liked the second
do it on Tuesday I don't care although I
feel like we'd probably get less people
if we did it on a Tuesday right okay cuz
Tuesday I mean Tuesday is such a weird
[ __ ] day yeah you know whatever
alright so that'll do it for episode 201
about some obscure Italian serial
killers and we will see you next time
bye
[Music]
you
[Music]